npr reports on twitter
who knew um they say the update isn't a
huge overhaul of the existing guidance
but it does represent an increasing
focus on individuals making their own
decisions about their level of risk and
how they want to mitigate that risk so
dr marcus plessia chief medical officer
for
i didn't look up what that is um so
npr's summary of the cdc's updated
guidelines and i'll show you the actual
cdc guidelines shortly the summary has
four bullet points
those exposed to the virus are no longer
required to quarantine
unvaccinated people now have the same
guidance as vaccinated people
students can stay in class after being
exposed to the virus and it's no longer
recommended to screen those without
symptoms
the second bullet point is the doozy
right unvaccinated people now have the
same guidance as vaccinated people
well
isn't it obvious then that hidden in
that bullet point is we recognize that
effectively you are the same
that
these these things for which so many
people's lives have been destroyed
and i'm not even talking about the
vaccine injured i'm talking about those
who have resisted and therefore have
lost opportunities have lost jobs have
lost family have lost friends have lost
all of these things
are now it's going to just quietly slip
in oh by the way it's fine
never mind
not even in our bat though not even in
our bed hold on um
let me let me put up the actual cd cdc
document uh let me put it up in the pdf
form though so i can show so here's the
cdc document that
it's it's in yeah
um
this is from august 11th a couple days
ago
cdc summary of guidance for minimizing
the impact of covet 19 on individual
persons communities and healthcare
systems united states august 2022
they of course put out a lot of these
things but this is the most recent one
and if we scroll down to see vaccines
and therapeutics to reduce medically
significant
uh illness covered 19 vaccination they
start by saying covet 19 vaccines are
highly protective against severe illness
and death and provide a lesser degree of
protection against asymptomatic and mild
infection
then receipt of a primary series alone
in the absence of being up to date with
vaccination through receipt of all
recommended booster doses provides
minimal protection against infection and
transmission
being up to date with vaccination
provides a transient period of increased
protection against infection and
transmission after the most recent dose
although protection can wane over time
that is a huge admission
and it's not that suddenly there's a lot
new a lot of new data out or there's a
lot of new um
analysis of existing data no this is
these are things that we have known
and
i don't know what prompted this report
now but what we are seeing is
we are we the cdc are going to put out
a report
that allows that allows those
organizations who have been listening to
us as if we are the law which they are
not
to start treating the unvaccinated like
full people again
while acknowledging that actually these
vaccines
what do they say provide minimal
protection
and provide a transient period of
increased protection
which wanes over time
so
i agree with the interpretation uh that
you put on it this is a tacit admission
yes right
what it functions as though the whole
point and again
long time viewers and listeners of dark
horse will remember discussions in which
we talk about the fact that sometimes
the
correct narrative
emerges in the end but what must not
happen from the point of view of these
power players is that they must not
vindicate those who were right about it
at the time so they do not go back and
clean up the record this is a perfect
example of that and i would say that
what they are doing
uh maybe catholics will bristle at this
but you know again this is not an attack
on catholics what they are doing though
is effectively doing this by encyclical
right
they are simply updating the wisdom from
the oracle right the person with the
connection to god is telling us what the
new wisdom on the vaccines is and the
new wisdom on the vaccines is that the
vaccinated and the unvaccinated are
equivalent now right they are not saying
actually our old story fell apart so
violently that we are forced to
backtrack and you by the way probably
ought to figure out who was right about
that in the first place and start
listening to them because they had us
beat from the get-go they will never say
that
so what they're doing is simply updating
the guidance and you're only supposed to
care yeah about the immediate belief
structure of the thing that hands down
the instructions by fiat that's why the
encyclical works here and
again
it is because whatever it is that has
captured the cdc is functioning to
create something that fits a
religion-shaped whole a religion shaped
whole is not about figuring the truth of
the universe it's about figuring out
what am i to do
right and what am i to do is oh i am now
to start treating the vaccinated and
unvaccinated equally which of course you
should have done all along right what's
more it lags
the reality right
it does not pay any attention to the
accumulating evidence that in fact these
vaccines have been harmful
right have actually crippled people's
immunity it completely ignores the fact
that even the data that they use to
argue
that these things
have some substantial effect that yes
wanes over time ignores the fact that
they create a vulnerability when you're
first given them right okay so
this is all you know coming down this is
this is oh by the way there's a burning
bush on that mountaintop over there and
i spoke with it and i came down with the
new wisdom about how it is that we are
to behave and you're never going to
believe this but i know that we were we
were busy scorning and throwing out of
our homes and our theaters the
unvaccinated but uh as of now uh we're
gonna stop doing that yeah right we yeah
we we encourage you to stop doing that
and you know i was for a while on a
weekly basis checking for with for
instance the local theater companies you
know who who's going to let us in
and i just i gave up a couple months ago
it's like i'm i'm done you know these
people are insane and they don't
understand anything about reality or
science and they're just never going to
let people who didn't take the jabs back
in and it turns out um that quietly
without you know without some of us
noticing i just got told yesterday oh
yeah actually um at least here in
portland oregon suddenly
um
most of these places are are letting in
the unbacks and again aren't checking
aren't asking for negative tests all of
it and
you know
again
the question that you know i'm stuck on
and i know that this is exactly part of
what you are what you were talking about
like i'm stuck like what changed what
happened guys what what happened in your
own head
and
for the most part people don't operate
that way you know i want to know what
happened and i want accountability and i
want some damn apologies at the societal
level and i want this to never happen
again
and instead what we see is well what the
cdc said but oh well it's just a oh
it's a lot of mumbling and a lot of like
footnotes and
uh and whereas
just if you would uh
put on my screen for a moment zach again
a tweet
uh from someone i don't know i don't
know who this is politically homeless
too is what they call themselves
uh a thread regarding the news of the
cdc's new guidelines in no particular
order i was not allowed to volunteer at
my kid's schools for over a year because
i wasn't vaccinated
a family refused to carpool with us
because they said they were
uncomfortable with their son sharing a
car with us we had been ratted out by a
mutual friend who said the other mom
well you do know they aren't vaccinated
right we were uninvited to good friends
to share a vacation house with them a
long-standing tradition was ended over
medical choice they all got covered
anyway of course my daughter couldn't
attend a theater production with her
school's theater company because
denver center rules
fifty percent of the restaurants and
many businesses in our neighborhood were
off limits to us i won't forget which
ones i'm just going to read this because
this mat like we don't have any of these
precise stories but it's it's a freaking
match for so many people's experience
we had to eat ice cold lunches out of a
backpack huddled outside with frozen
hands and we skied at vale resort
because we weren't allowed inside the
lodges i could never get warm
i bailed on the rest of the season after
just two days of my pass wasn't worth it
i wasn't allowed to stay in a hotel or
eating any restaurant for a work trip to
dc i had to cancel all together as it
made travel there impossible
my husband having trained already for
six months was banned from participating
in an ironman event
a group of his friends told him over
text that he was endangering them and
their families and they told him he
couldn't stay in the airbnb with them
for and
they told him he couldn't stay in the
airbnb with them for a trip they had
been planning they no longer speak to
him
i was called a conspiracy theorist by
dear friends and was left in the dust by
them socially i would have given one of
my kidneys to these friends they cut me
off after a wax that didn't stop
transmission or infection
my teens experienced unbelievable
amounts of stress
we didn't book a trip i was disinvited
my husband was fired so yes and goes on
and on just i alighted some of that so
yes i am seething a bit right now having
read the cdc's new guidance knowing that
this is what the guidance should have
been all along minus
minus the ridiculous masking i want
apologies and i want assurances that
this won't happen again i know that
won't come though
this that thread speaks for a tremendous
number of people and
those
even those who became skeptical
uh who didn't get boosted who did their
first shot or first two shots and then
said no actually no more i'm not seeing
it
this set of experiences is invisible to
to a majority of americans at least and
i think in most the weird world and that
invisibility means it is more likely to
be able to happen again
yes
um
i
of course share exactly your sense of
ire and your desire for
an apology because of course an apology
would involve some power to prevent it
from happening again and exactly
reference the apology exactly none of
that has been conveyed here right now of
course again that is perfectly
predictable that it would go through
this so the real question is those of us
in our position how do we push the point
and say
not good enough not nearly good enough
and
here's the never again problem okay we
had a system
in which reality was right arrived at
through processes journalistic processes
dialectic processes scientific processes
that's how western civilization works
they
bypassed the entire thing they
decapitated it and they handed us down
directly as if they had gone up a
mountain and talked to a [ __ ] burning
bush they handed us
directly you know as if from god here is
the things you are to believe and to act
upon they were wrong they did tremendous
harm and they brutally punished those of
us who stood up and said you couldn't
possibly know what you're saying the
mechanisms to know do not exist you are
lying if you are claiming to know these
things because you couldn't even if your
conclusions had been accurate you are
lying and claiming that you can know
these things when they claimed to know
them because they couldn't possibly have
known them at the time and i love the
metaphor of decapitation here because
then what they did is they took the head
no longer attached to the system of
science to the dialectic to the process
by which we actually come to understand
truth they stuck it on a stick and they
put it in front of us and had it jaw off
at us and a lot of people believed it
said okay that talking head
must represent science and truth and
reality and democracy it must to return
to some of the earlier points to be
looking around going like
you guys could see right you guys can
see that we're at eclipse edge
and many people are saying i don't what
are you talking about we're good it's
all good
you cannot go to the restaurants right
so it's fine right which to me sounds a
little bit like uh sorry we jumped the
gun jews are now welcome at the
restaurants and it's like okay i
remember not being welcome there last
week and uh okay it's all well and good
that i have more restaurants to choose
from this week i like the salad there
but but now i know
now i know what you're capable of
and uh frankly i'm not going to those
restaurants
right i just the point is okay you've
announced what team you're on and the
fact that your team is playing nice this
week is irrelevant to me you've told me
you've told me who you are i will say
too with regard to um i haven't gone and
looked at the various restaurants
because i think some of them are also
lifting their their vaccine mandates
here in portland um but on the at the
theater sites
there's always some fine print and it's
actually the same font size as the
regular but it seems like the fine print
that they kind of don't expect you to
read which says we can of course uh
reverse this reversal at any time um if
if guidelines change guidelines
guidelines from whom on what basis if
someone anyone walks in and says i have
guidelines oh okay right the guidelines
have changed therefore nope not you so
what they are is saying uh we are on
team encyclical
right so the encyclical has it of course
we're going to follow the cdc wisdom
because you know it's the cdc after all
but of course you know
you know we're going to follow the
current cdc wisdom and nobody can tell
you that except the oracle you know what
it's going to look like a month from now
so yeah there's that not fortune tellers
are we
writing
all we can do is follow the cdc right
well no not when and this is really the
important point is
you do have a choice
right yeah the cdc has been wrong
the entire time right it's been wrong on
essentially every major issue if you had
done the opposite of what it suggested
you would have been far better off
um yes go to the beach
don't get back definitely go to the
beach do get yourself some ivermectin
some hydroxychloroquine
right get your d get your d right all of
these things so
the last point i want to make is what is
your real choice if the cdc is now
functioning by oracle and encyclical
right and anthony fauci is the reason
everybody's going to medical school and
that tells you exactly what kind of
doctors they're going to be does that
mean he's both science and medicine i
think it does hmm yeah yeah that's uh
that's the big too that's a lot of
weight on his rather small shoulders but
um
anyway
i don't think there's any reason to talk
about his his size there's so many
reasons to rail against anthony fauci
he's a giant there's no question about
it
no i mean that he is a giant he's a
giant threat to uh our medical
well-being but nonetheless
here's the thing
in this process it was necessary for
this oracle
encyclical fatwa
cancel process the one that declared
mal information to be terrorism and then
in the fine print said oh mal
information are true things that cause
you to distrust your government right
that's your department of homeland
security
it was necessary to target people who
were using some other process spotted
the cdc guidance as nonsense
and were speaking about it openly
basically trying to use the process that
western civilization naturally does use
[Music]